[Applause]
what began as a sit-in protest of
parliament quickly turned into a violent
confrontation
police fired tear gas on the crowds and
moved in to break up any resistance
the protesters say president felix
tishiketti plans to steal next year's
election
and they'll keep up their campaign until
he agrees to talk
we're fighting for a credible electoral
law from the parliament which will allow
us to have a good election next year so
that we can kick out president felix
tishketi we're suffering in this country
because of his fake governance
this fight will continue from now until
we have a good election in 2023.
president xi zakiri must go next year
peacefully through election
we will come back tomorrow till we have
an agreement around the electoral law
became president in 2019 in the
democratic republic of congo's first
peaceful transition of power
but now he's pushing through a reform to
electoral laws that opponents fear will
be used to disqualify his main rivals
the opposition wants national consensus
on the best way to hold a fair election
the president is controlling everything
as a dictator the only way to put
pressure on him is to call on our
population to take action against this
regime
tishiger's reform plan has become a
rallying cry for the opposition if they
aren't included in the process it's
likely the protests like these will
continue
and failure to reach consensus on next
year's election could further complicate
the nation's struggle for democracy
vinton monaghan al-jazeera